[موسيقى]
يتجول الأشخاص [الموسيقى] الأجانب أمام متاجرنا أو عندما
يأتون إلى المتجر ، فإنهم دائمًا ما
ينظرون حولهم ويشعرون وكأنك تعلم أنهم
يعتقدون أنه متجر Apple Store ،
وسرعان ما يدركون أنك تعرف في الواقع أن
هذا متجر أزياء  أنت تعرف
من جميع مقاطع الفيديو على الجدران بالإضافة إلى
الأجهزة اللوحية التي تعرفها بنقرة واحدة وهم
يدركون أن هذا متجر أزياء ولكن
مع تجربة فريدة ومختلفة للغاية ،
أردنا الجمع بين
التجارب المادية والرقمية
وإنشاء تجربة رقمية فريدة  المتجر
عرفنا أن التجربة الأصلية
للعميل الذي اخترناه للتجربة الرقمية
للتصفح من خلال تطبيق التطبيق وموقع
الويب كان شيئًا
أحبه العملاء وعرفوه بينما
كانوا
يريدون دائمًا أن يكونوا قادرين على لمس
المنتج.  أن تكون قادرًا على تجربة المنتج
وأيضًا الإشباع الفوري ، مما يعني أن
تأخذ المنتجات معهم إلى المنزل
على الفور عندما يتسوقون أيضًا ،
لذا فالأمر بسيط كما تعلم عند
دخولك إلى المتجر ، يمكنك اختيار أحد
الأجهزة اللوحية التي لدينا داخل  قم
بالتخزين في الوقت الذي يناسبك
وطريقتك في التصفح
وتجرب المنتجات التي لدينا
في المتجر ، يمكنك المرور بهذه
التجربة بمجرد إضافة بعض
المنتجات المختلفة إلى سلة التسوق الخاصة بك ،
ثم يتم إرسال هذه العناصر تلقائيًا إلى
غرفة القياس الخاصة بك ، لذلك دون الحاجة إلى
التحدث إلى شخص ما ودون الحاجة إلى
رؤية منتج على الإطلاق ، يتم عرض جميع العناصر
تلقائيًا في
غرفة القياس ، ما نسميه خزانة تفتح
والعناصر جاهزة لك لتجربتها
ونحن الآن قادرون  لمنحك خيارات
الأحجام المختلفة المتاحة
بنقرة زر واحدة ، يمكنك بالفعل
طلب الحجم الآخر هناك بعد
دقيقتين من فتح خزانتك مرة أخرى
وسيكون العنصر الخاص بك جاهزًا لك لتجربه
أيضًا
أعضاء فريقنا في  المتجر لذا
فهم في الواقع مستشارون للأزياء
وليسوا فرق مبيعات نتراجع ونسمح
لك بالحضور إلينا إذا كان لديك سؤال
حول المتجر أو إذا كنت ترغب في الحصول على
بعض النصائح المتعلقة بالموضة بشكل صحيح ، فأنا ذاهب
لتناول العشاء الليلة وأنا  لديك بالفعل
هذا الحذاء ، فأنت تعلم أن الفستان الذي يبدو
جيدًا سيبدو جيدًا به
سيكونون هناك لمساعدتك ومساعدتك
عندما تحتاج إلى
[موسيقى]
أجنبية